i am
in front of the hyundai department store
near the samsung
um subway exit it's a lovely warm day
next to me is the intercontinental hotel
amazing again tall buildings here
everywhere you look
and i just finished walking through an
absolutely amazing mall
modern the attention to detail the
attention to quality is just
mind-blowing
there is such a difference with the
korea that i saw
40 years ago such a difference between
what we saw in vietnam
and and even compared to home it's just
another another level of sophistication
i am just completely
blown away by what i see here and
totally motivated to work on my korean
and just come from the bookstore with
more books i'm gonna have to get another
bag
and um see if i can read them to catch
up to the level of the material that i'm
doing on link
looking forward to meeting everyone
tonight
at our meetup but i am just so impressed
my korean of course is really struggling
uh there's no way i can quite make out
what they're saying to me
uh
to get my career and i've invested so
much in it and have a passive knowledge
to get it to where it's active i'm gonna
have to come here and spend at least a
month or two and i
definitely intend to do so i i'm just so
turned on
by and blown away by about what i've
seen here so far in seoul
and we'll catch up to you later